[Applaudissements]
alors cette académie sera ouverte pour
des jeunes âgés de 16 à 23 ans on
démarre par des journées de détection la
semaine prochaine 9 et le 12
donc il s'agira de former les jeunes sur
le plan sportif mais également d'avoir
un suivi scolaire et médical donc on va
leur proposer un programme pouvant aller
de 5 à 12 heures en plus des séances
collectives sur la semaine avec un vrai
contenu heures rugbystique et ce sera
vraiment tourner sur l'individuel voilà
le développement individuel sportif et
bien sûr sans oublier le le développe le
développement professionnel pour qu'ils
acquièrent une qualification
professionnelle à la sortie
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est de former nos
nos jeunes joueurs et joueuses au plus
haut niveau bien sûr pour alimenter
notre équipe seniors filles et garçons
puisque on avoue on ouvre cette année
une équipe féminine mais également de
pouvoir les amener au plus haut niveau
donc s'ils vont au dessus de notre
niveau tant mieux c'est notre travail
aussi notre ambition alors c'est un
projet qu'on parle depuis quelques
années effectivement avec le président
et puis qu'on a mis en marche
on a décidé de mettre en marche at elle
cette année principalement dû à
l'activité très minime qu'on a eu on
s'est dit voilà pourquoi on pourra
travailler sur ce projet